hey what's going on its bill bird it's
time for the Monday morning podcast for
Monday May 30th 2016 how are you how's
it going oh hi oh look at you what do
you doing for Memorial Day yeah you got
to fill up the above-ground pool oh god
bless you god bless you'll be over with
a couple of mellows you know I've been
drinking late Stacey Stacey Stacey Thank
You Alvin yeah you know what I've been
drinking lately I don't know why I
started drinking the Coors Light again
remember them silver bullets [ __ ]
prom night how many did you get is your
class oh Jesus Christ
happy Memorial Day everybody thank you
to everybody in the military for doing
what it is that you do so that morons
like me can run their [ __ ] Yap and
not have a black van pull up and take me
away to get reeducate 'add that's it
happy happy happy day off on a Monday
things they should have one of these a
[ __ ] a month you know they should have
one three-day weekend a month if Donald
Trump or Bernie Sanders would get on
board with that the two candidates
that's a simple one the people once all
we need to want them to and they're
going to ram ol Hillary write down your
[ __ ] L cuckoo clock face yourself write
down your [ __ ] throat that's what
they're going to do i watch this clip on
facebook so you know it had to be true
with Chris Matthews right was basically
just mine [ __ ] everybody saying that
Hillary was going to win it and blah
blah blah blah blah just saying when she
wins it and all that type of [ __ ] she
wasn't doing like it he wasn't doing
like a dude I call the type of thing
he's just doing that like the rich the
rich liberals you know those ones you
know the ones who act like they care
about anybody else
they actually they're worse than rich
Republicans because Republicans don't
act like they give a [ __ ] about other
people but rich liberals ah they're the
[ __ ] worst bleeding-heart
you know caring about
everybody in their [ __ ] gated
communities oh Jesus bill the [ __ ] did
you have for breakfast what did I have
for breakfast I had two eggs over AG two
eggs over-easy and I always buy these
eggs from this [ __ ] lilies farm
because it sounds like it's some chick
down the street who just has a henhouse
and she's making them for my
neighborhood but God knows you know it's
some giant corporation and I don't know
what the [ __ ] they're doing with these
eggs they have the thinnest slash
hardest egg shelf ever so if you tap
real lightly poop in the bottom of the
[ __ ] pant they will not break and if
you keep in this this one [ __ ] sweet
spot that you hit the you hit the
[ __ ] eggshell that will actually
crack and it won't break the yolk all
right I don't know if you guys know
about this know this about me but I do
not break egg yolks okay and I'm also
superstitious when it comes to breaking
egg yolks I feel like if you break the
[ __ ] yolk that means your day is
going to be a [ __ ] show right
it's a metaphor you had a plan and the
whole thing went to [ __ ] and then you
got a scramble it up right that's how I
look at it so not only did I broke one
the other one was okay but then I was
just so [ __ ] frustrated because you
want them runny because then you still
have the nutrition in there right all
these people to have it over hog yeah
over hard like your [ __ ] arteries
right so I go to flip the thing and I'm
so [ __ ] frustrated that it's going to
turn into basically a fried egg sandwich
I got mad and I go to flip the other one
I broke that one too I just was in my
kitchen by myself going yeah the whole
thing right yes the whole thing then
Nene downstairs how you arrived yeah bye
what are you doing I just making some
eggs honey doesn't sound like it oh god
I got the interrogation right here comes
the [ __ ] interrogation like Norbert
Leo Butz his wife on bloodline oh my god
that character is driving me up the
[ __ ] wall not saying the actress
she's phenomenal but that whole dynamic
it's like can you just shut up
can you leave the man alone is anybody
watching bloodline I'm not going to ruin
any of this [ __ ] but you got to [ __ ]
watch it you got to watch it I'm like
I'm already five episodes into season
two it just came out you know I had a
nice three-day weekend so Billy [ __ ]
red cakes here I I've been [ __ ]
Netflix the whole weekend started off
the weekend I watched to do over Adam
Sandler's new movie with David Spade it
was [ __ ] great I always loved
Sandler's [ __ ] movies and I loved
spades character I it's hard to talk
about a movie without saying what the
[ __ ] happens just watch it and also just
being a fan of people out here in
Hollywood that do their own goddamn
thing
I guess Sandler's movies crush it on
Netflix so he's like well why [ __ ]
take it to the movie theater I'll just
take it right to you so he cut a deal
with them like his next I don't afford
to six movies and they went right right
to that so I believe this is the first
one and I [ __ ] loved it man I love it
I got I can't care what happens but
there was just one thing that Sandler
did and I was like that's probably going
to be the most disgusting thing I'm
going to see for the first half of the
year and then something else happens
that involves a [ __ ] old lady so there
you go
I just primed the pump check it out if
you get a chance and I've been watching
bloodline and then somebody else
recommended I am Road comic and it was
about just these comics Wayne Federman
these guys doing this road gig and
enjoyed all of that enjoyed all of that
and but I mentioned earlier that check
those out if you can't check them out of
here anyways so I mentioned earlier that
I am in a much more upbeat mood than
I've been in a while you know and I know
what you think you're Billa what would
you would you get another bottle of
booze no not at all not at all I finally
went to a chiropractor all right I went
to a chiropractor and I never I never go
to the doctor
all right because that's how I was
brought up Christ I'm telling you Billy
Christ you gotta get down there and and
they're going to find something and
addictive is just going to charge you up
[ __ ] want them take a goddamn aspirin
alright you hang from a pull-up bar
you'll be fine alright I came from a
family at a time where you didn't go to
the [ __ ] doctor if you went to the
[ __ ] and you don't go to the doctor you
don't take your car no mechanic because
they're going to [ __ ] and find something
so I finally go to the chiropractor
because at this point I told you I'm
literally in the writers room I have
cushions from this couch on the floor
and I lay on the floor and I call it
floor pitching I just pitched jokes
laying on the floor and then when it
gets to some critical part of the story
I then stand up to see what's going on
and then I lay back down again then I
just lay on the ground what if ba what
if Fred said uh you know I'll put you
through the [ __ ] wall right that's
what I do
so I finally couldn't take it anymore
and a buddy of mine works on the show
said I got a great chiropractor and I
file I was just like you know what you
got to let that [ __ ] suburban Boston
[ __ ] go okay there's no way if they
always [ __ ] up everybody would still
be going to him so I end up going down
there and this guy was a [ __ ] wizard
unbelievable right he literally like put
his hand right in my lower back and was
just pushing on my spine like on one
side of it and was going on seems like
you have a an older injury here from a
long time ago I was like yeah how the
[ __ ] did you know that because now I
could tell because this is bold day like
I have bulging discs and he goes AG like
oh yeah [ __ ] you know one of my when I
was in fourth grade a you know I was
into wrestling and the body-mind knew
how to do the figure-four leglock and
unfortunately the only way to teach
someone how to do it is to put a minute
and he put me in the [ __ ] thing and
when I sat up to try to free my leg I
said the first time I felt something go
out in my back and then the next time
was playing football freshman year of
high school pickup football
I didn't play organized
didn't play organized because I got a D
in math in fifth grade and that was that
was that was my retirement like when
Jordan retired in 2003 except by never I
won one championship and I never
returned but anyways he was able to fix
all of that [ __ ] I immediately felt
better the next day I was sore and then
over the weekend like like last night
for the first time in like two months I
was able to sit down for a significant
period of time and have no pain
whatsoever and I just been doing all
these stretches and the biggest one is
I've been doing that you know the up dog
yoga stretch for your was he so as
muscle in the front I just thought it
connected you talk to your bottom just
where your hips were it ran
perpendicular to your waist I didn't
realize that it came up and then kind of
made like an S turn right to like the
middle of your body he was explaining to
me I forget what it is but like I've
been stretching that thing and do my
Vietnamese Gambler squat and a couple of
runners stretch and I think by this time
next week I should be I should be right
as rain and dude he [ __ ] crack my
back I didn't know he was going to do it
I was laying on my back and he goes all
right bringing knees up bring them over
to the side just let it relax relax let
me have all the weight and [ __ ] right
there Fred and I just started [ __ ]
laughing like dude what the [ __ ]
because I always thought it was like
they were cracking your bones
I guess there's gas that they're
releasing in there I have no [ __ ]
idea but anyways I don't know I got
something I always have to remember that
just because something's a racket
doesn't mean that there's not somebody
that's really good at it you know what I
mean like think of the reputation that
comedians have we don't have a good
reputation we're on off stage we're
attention [ __ ] we got the [ __ ]
lampshade on our head and we tell
[ __ ] awful jokes yet despite that
there's still your [ __ ] you know David
tells chappelle's Louis CK's and all
those [ __ ] guys so that's why I guess
what you got to do you got to find the
louis c.k of chiropractors before you
[ __ ] them going and i think i did
so I don't know this is so I don't know
how to get out of this this is just
something good happen to me and I told
you the story and not the bad happen so
I don't have any jokes about it other
than I couldn't find the [ __ ] place
you know I was driving over with my
phone right it's directing me over there
and then in the last second right when I
needed it where the building was I hit
like a whatever a dead zone and I had
nothing and I walked up to the building
was one of those partially like rented
building so it looked like it was
abandoned from where I was and I'm
looking in and up by now I'm already
losing my [ __ ] I'm like right it's
nobody then I just see this nurse walk
by looking at me with their scrubs on
like what the [ __ ] is your problem is
just that I had to kind of be like play
it off and it's kind of follow her
around the part of the building that was
actually being used I swear to god man I
need to learn how to have patience I
just I had zero [ __ ] patience I have
zero [ __ ] tolerance all of that [ __ ]
and I don't know it's really going to be
the death of me
I really gotta learn to just [ __ ]
relax it's weird little [ __ ] little [ __ ]
[ __ ] driving at the wall
major [ __ ] or major pains in the ass I
just laughs I don't
yes that was driving my lovely wife back
from went over the mall she picked up a
few things we got all the way home by
back was starting to kill me and she
realized she left one of her shopping
bags in in a store and she flipped the
[ __ ] out I just and I was like eh that's
fine fine I think I don't give a [ __ ]
right I Drive all the way back my back's
killing me I didn't give a [ __ ]
totally relaxed that was fine right but
then like an old lady walks in a
crosswalk and I have to wait an extra
six seconds to make a left and I
literally have a meltdown for the life
of me I can't figure out why that is but
anyways speaking of great stand-up
comedians Doug
and hope put something up he wrote
something he's friends with Johnny Depp
and he's going through this brutal
[ __ ] divorce and I just want to give
him props for sticking up for his friend
and everything and saying something
because you know you know what's really
so [ __ ] up all right it's all the [ __ ]
that happens to women that guys do women
is [ __ ] up but there has been a slight
over correction now where if somebody a
woman just says you do something before
you ever try to convict it it just gets
put in the paper it gets put all over
the internet and then all you [ __ ]
morons are 90 percent of you on the
[ __ ] Internet just take it as truth
take it as fun why do you take it is
truth because you want it to be true
because he's doing better than you in
life I mean it's just [ __ ]
unbelievable I really believed it's okay
if somebody gets accused okay of rape or
domestic violence they should not
publicize the person's name until
they're convicted of it I think that's
more than fair considering all the
[ __ ] dopes out there that the second
they read something you know let it
[ __ ] see what happens first see what
the [ __ ] happens first all had bet that
whole thing now that all you got to do
is just say the amount of [ __ ] guys
who've been falsely accused of that [ __ ]
it's like you're literally [ __ ] with
their ability to get a job you're
[ __ ] with their reputation you know
the deal do like domestic violence and
anything involving sex that [ __ ] never
goes that never goes away
so I don't know I just want to you know
give Stanhope [ __ ] crops were
actually sticking up for the guy because
there's a lot of people you know because
of the stigma around that even if they
know it isn't true they're afraid to
throw their hat in the [ __ ] ring
right now I don't know what the [ __ ]
happened or whatever okay I'm just
saying the fact that somebody finally
just said hey this guy hasn't been tried
for anything yet he's a
friend of mine I know we would never do
this it was it was refreshing to finally
read that and for somebody to finally
say you know what I believe is you
shouldn't put somebody's name out there
until you know 100% tried and convicted
they definitely did that [ __ ] and then
if they did tar and feather them but to
do that to somebody and also to give
that weapon to somebody that they can
just [ __ ] say that and blackmail you
with that and really destroy your
reputation I don't it's [ __ ]
reprehensible so there's another thing
that isn't really funny you know that
you know it's like all those Duke
lacrosse players the shipping just
[ __ ] faces all over the [ __ ] and
you know to this day despite the fact
that they were totally vindicated
despite the fact that there was a 34:30
talking about how bad they got
railroaded despite all of that you know
that's still going to affect their lives
you know they're still going to be
somebody going yeah but you know
something up and you know somebody when
they get mad and they got nothing else
to say they're going to call him a
rapist or something like that you
[ __ ] know that they're gonna so I
don't I know everything it was good to
see and of course it was Stanhope stand
up stand ups a good [ __ ] man as is
Johnny Depp by the way two times he's a
big fan of fan it comes out the shows
he's [ __ ] humble as hell you know
gentle one of most gentle [ __ ] people
ever you know I mean look listen to me
it's not as [ __ ] I talk you know what I
mean you'd understand it if it came you
know somebody said that about me that he
[ __ ] snapped like Posey and [ __ ]
Dirty Dozen I know I barely know the guy
I've only met him a few [ __ ] times
but like Adam I really tend to believe
what the [ __ ] Stanhope is saying and i
100% believe he should not be putting
somebody's [ __ ] name out there just
because somebody said it you know
[ __ ] a please [ __ ] state is brutal
she's going for [ __ ] spousal support
you know going for [ __ ] spousal
support which means he's got to pay her
for like the rest of her [ __ ] life
she married the guys for 15
[ __ ] months and you know what kills
me about that person she's going to
[ __ ] go to the Beyonce concert right
all debate is independent and she while
you watch you throw a [ __ ] hand up
Wow [ __ ] gets me heated alright here we
go here we go is there any [ __ ]
ribbons for guys falsely accused of rape
and domestic violence
you know do they get their month you
know what will the NFL wear a color for
them of course they want their honey
okay look anyways alright here we go
let's talk about let's talk about that
game six holy [ __ ] [ __ ]
Game six OKC Golden State Warriors and
when I say holy [ __ ] [ __ ] not only do
I mean it was a great game I mean holy
[ __ ] [ __ ] you guys gonna have to sit
here and listen to a man who never
watched his basketball talk about
basketball actually I watched the most
Pebble watch this year and I watched the
Celtics mainly [ __ ] brutal man I'm
not gonna lie I always root for the
underdogs I was going for OKC right and
you know Golden State got theirs last
year I like I you know I've been to a
home game of of the Thunder the fans are
[ __ ] unreal and I love their stadium
it's like a college stadium you know
it's not like [ __ ] triple decker
luxury boxes like down the Staples
Center which every time I go in and it's
a part of me that gets really sad for
like true Laker fans true King fans true
clipper fans that they got banished that
[ __ ] high up it's [ __ ] ridiculous
they got a goddamn nightclub in there
you know where you can hang out
afterwards it's the stupidest [ __ ] ever
right I mean while all the [ __ ] the
real fans that have been hanging out you
know the only real fan in the lower
level of at the Lakers game
you got to Dyan Cannon and Jack
Nicholson they've been there for [ __ ]
ever and I think it was Jack first but
anyways and I I've seen I saw Kevin
Durant play when he was still sent at
Key Arena when he's still with the
Sonics and I was at that game when OKC
was playing the Miami Heat and Chris
Bosh gotten in
one of the thunders guys faces and Tiran
immediately walked over and said some
[ __ ] and broke it up and then he like
was really [ __ ] you know look like
not yelling but just laying down the
Lada was teammate and afterwards they
asked him what he said he said I just
told them there's a lot of phony tough
guys in the league and that guy's one of
them and right there I mean he was like
20 to 23 when he did that I was like
that you got it you can't not love that
guy right so I'm rooting for these guys
and it's the classic [ __ ] thing about
a team that knows how to win another one
that didn't they had those [ __ ] they
actually they actually won the [ __ ]
game they had the [ __ ] I can't say they
went they had at 1 they walked by 7 with
4 and a half minutes left and they were
playing like they was down by 15 and
[ __ ] the Warriors they were like they
were like this patient like a you know
when you see like I want to Python grab
something and it wraps itself around you
and it just chill it and every time you
ask ask exhale it just [ __ ] goes a
little tighter and a little tighter you
know and then you like you can't [ __ ]
breathe you pass out it's over that's
all they did you what we watched that
game they never increased the tempo of
their game they just [ __ ] they were
like Jason and Friday the 13th you know
when someone's running away OKC was the
victim running away looking over their
shoulder so they're tripping over logs
and [ __ ] and they just [ __ ] walked up
on them and that was it
[ __ ] machete to the back of the neck
they were playing like they went down by
15 when they were up by 7 and then they
just started coming down the court they
stopped passing the [ __ ] ball and
jagged it would that was that was one of
the most devastating losses I've seen of
a home team in a long [ __ ] time they
just ripped their hearts out
[ __ ] held it up to their faces and
then threw it in the crowd there was
dead [ __ ] silence except for those 20
unbelievable stereotypical jerk-off
California sports fans that hung around
the [ __ ] worst not all of them but
80% of them they are the [ __ ] way
maybe there was a touch of the Yolo
douche that was [ __ ] going on right
you know the white guys with the hat to
the side you know two of them DJ right
they was standing behind on all of the
all of the [ __ ] announces their Nia
killed me when we were watching it she
was [ __ ] making fun of Shaq he said
he's what his big blue suit his big
round head she said he looked like one
of those talking M&Ms anyways but Jesus
Christ klay Thompson my god
at what point are you going to cover the
guy this is what so [ __ ] up about the
NBA you know when when when when I was
[ __ ] him when Steph Curry goes down
the lane for like the 50th [ __ ] time
look oz over here Lou Dan will be you'll
be do and he's in the air back in the
day that you would have got you would
have got [ __ ] brought down to earth
on the back of your head that would have
been it and everyone would have stood up
and pushed and shoved and nobody would
have got a ejected he's [ __ ] like
that's something because I watched very
little basketball for a long time during
my stand-up career and I just cannot
believe the way you can just coast down
the [ __ ] lane you know what I mean
back in the day if you tried to go down
the lane you had to be a [ __ ] man you
know you knew you were going to it's up
you know you could get away with it once
maybe twice and then that was it it was
like when Michael Vick was running
around as a quarterback you know
eventually one of those linebackers was
going to have an opportunity and yeah it
was going to you know this you know if
you're a running quarterback you know
eventually you know it's almost like
considered like I feel it's considered
like a cheap [ __ ] play like we got
you guys covered you know what I mean
and then you're just going to [ __ ]
you know run and then [ __ ] slide on
your ass for a first down that makes
people mad on the defense and eventually
you're not going to have time to go down
or they don't give a [ __ ] that you're
going down and they're going to take the
[ __ ] define and I'm amazed how that
has been taken
out of the [ __ ] game these guys just
glide watch I want to say when Mikael
hit Rambis I don't even know if there
was a foul there must have been a foul
but nobody was ejected that would have
been like what I don't know whatever the
suspensions are nowadays three to five
game suspension but anyways klay
Thompson Jesus Christ the [ __ ] guy
was unconscious and I got to tell you
man I just the only reason why I think
OKC can win Game seven is nobody thinks
they can and that always makes me feel
like Vegas is going to win a ton of
[ __ ] money I actually have a bet I
called in the I am Rappaport podcast
because we Rappaport anytime anything
bad happens to two [ __ ] Boston teams
he's just got a hard-on for it you know
what I mean and then he tries to act
like he doesn't give a [ __ ] about
baseball and then when I bring up how
successful the Yankees are he flips up
that's right that's right when we
[ __ ] prison race you he flips out it
it literally ages that man what has
happened over the last decade and a half
what we have accomplished with only four
teams even our [ __ ] soccer team if
you want to throw that in right even
they want to championship it Apple
absolutely [ __ ] devastates that man
you know and all he's got is the two
giant Super Bowls which to be honest
with you you know I don't give a [ __ ] if
you told me 15 years ago hey the
Patriots are going to go to six Super
Bowls and win for aful do you think I'm
going to cry about together - I don't
give a [ __ ] four and two I'll [ __ ]
take that you know else would take that
the [ __ ] giant if they could have
gone to 6 and 1/4 and why wouldn't you
well you know something they would
probably say 1 & 2 against the Patriots
is better and I would actually believe
that I would actually believe that so
whatever you know what I mean but that's
the kind of sports fan I am I don't have
this blind hatred you know this is the
thing this is the thing above me as much
as I sound like an upper deck
I'm really not I am the way I drink I am
the way I talk the way I curse I am an
upper deck guy but I am a logical
son-of-a-bitch I'm not saying I'm blocks
feet I'm on the mezzanine level okay I'm
just that much closer to the [ __ ] to
the field now Rappaport Rappaport is
upper deck all day all [ __ ] day and
if he hears this he's going to say he's
actually proud of it Rappaport that guy
at the top of the [ __ ] stadium going
is anybody looking is anybody looking
any [ __ ] takes a piss up in the
corner you know what I mean he actually
really is more like a Philly Fed than a
New York fan he can't help it he just
can't help with the man the man has in
and when I hear his hatred towards
Boston sports and when I hear his
excitement every time they reinstate the
Brady suspension it just makes me it
like a I came and tell you how happy it
makes me that there's a New York sports
fan that is experiencing this level of
joy that something bad is finally
happening to a Boston team this century
it never used to be that way
you know you know what New York sports
fans are - Boston fans they like your
big brother that used to be able to can
beat you up until you above 14 and then
you finally kicked his ass you know you
know threw them down the flight of
stairs you know you felt them quit and
it's [ __ ] over
you know you need but it's never over
because you know at some point some
point in your 30 something's going to
come something's going to happen at like
a family reunion and they're going to
come at you one more time right you just
give me old front facelock right into a
back bodydrop and then it's [ __ ] over
once you hear that body hit that
linoleum floor right the ankle just
clips the counter they're [ __ ] done
I love Rappaport you know all right he's
another pasty [ __ ] human being is out
of his [ __ ] mind just like me all
right let's read a little bit of
advertising blue advertising hair for
and when I say little I mean little we
only got two reads every
ah when you try to make the read funny
there goes the honey
right out the [ __ ] door I dollar
shank love everybody guys I slash we
really appreciate you listening to the
show and wanted to do something to thank
you who writes this so I flash we
contacted my slash our friends at
dollarshaveclub.com
and arrange for them to give new members
a month a month of the executive razor
for free just for buying a tube of dr.
cabbie I didn't do this this is this is
a bald-faced lie I never did this I'm /
we're super excited they're doing it for
you listen well can't just put it my own
words Dollar Shave club's got a great
[ __ ] deal I'm happy they're doing
this for you because when I was your age
I had to pay through the nose for
[ __ ] expensive [ __ ] razor blades
that are made out of [ __ ] plastic and
recycled coke cans and they charge you
like [ __ ] 25 bucks or a pack it's
complete horseshit
somebody saw the opportunity to be like
hey what if I didn't make a 900 million
percent profit and I just made a [ __ ]
100 percent profit right this guy here
at Dollar Shave Club he's like the Robin
Hood of the shaving industry all right
here's the deal dollarshaveclub.com
delivers amazing razors right to you
[ __ ] dog for a third of the price of
what the gree razor corporations charge
you that means when you join Dollar
Shave Club you can afford to shave with
a fresh blade anytime you want which
feels fantastic get first-class shave
when you use the executive blade that's
without even hurting your wallet and
when you use the executive with the
adductor cavity dr. carver shea butter
the blade just gently glides for the
smoothest shave shea butter isn't your
average shave cream its unique
conditioning formula with high quality
natural ingredients leaving your skin
feeling unbelievably soft and smooth now
is a great time to join Dollar Shave
Club trinket the court line again new
members who buy a tube of shave let us
get a month of the exact
you've raised it for free take advantage
of this special offer today it's
available by going to
dollarshaveclub.com / / that's
dollarshaveclub.com / bar
dollarshaveclub.com / / all right
o blue apron everybody blue apron what's
going on you're dating you got somebody
coming over and you want to cook them a
meal but you're not confident with your
cooking skills no worries blue aprons
here all right
not all ingredients are created equal
fresh high-quality ingredients taste
better and are better for you so it's
important to know where your food comes
from blue apron knows when you cook with
incredible ingredients you make
incredible meals so they set the highest
quality standards for their community of
artisanal suppliers family-run farms
fisheries and ranchers
how would you investigate something like
that this is like some Trump [ __ ] where
do we have the greatest food ever
whether it's Japanese ramen noodles
wild-caught Alaskan salmon or heirloom
tomatoes blue apron is bringing you the
best for less than $10 per meal
10 bucks per meal come on blue apron
delivers seasonal recipes along with
pre-portioned ingredients to make
delicious home-cooked meals new recipes
are created each week by blue aprons
culinary team and are not repeated
within a year let's welcome crazy
flexible customers your recipes each
weeks are based on your preferences
choose delivery options if it fits your
needs
there's no weekly commitment so you only
get deliveries when you want each meal
comes with a step-by-step easy-to-follow
recipe card and pre portion ingredients
and can be prepared in 40 minutes left
the only way to be easier is if they
came over and cooked it for you check
out this week's menu they should have
like somebody from Blue Man Group come
over right with the blue apron you know
is there any blue food blue potatoes I
don't know check out this week's menu
and get your two meals free why didn't
they do that on Breaking Bad they should
add a guy from Blue Man Group smoking
that blue meth and that right there is
why I didn't write for the show all
right freeze it
all right by going to blue apron comm
slash burg you will love how it feels
and tastes to create incredible
home-cooked meals with blue apron don't
wait that's blue apron comm / / blue
apron comm a better way to cook
check out this weekend's menu and get to
two of your meals for free that's right
with free shipping sorry I forgot that
part
alright let's get back to the podcast
here
alright so Oh Oh Billy [ __ ] fat cakes
I'm in a writers room and I hope I blew
out my [ __ ] sciatic nerve right I so
I have not been working out and I've
been trying to eat the best I can but I
finally bit the bullet stepped on the
[ __ ] scale the other day I was 183 so
my fighting weight 172 I went down to
163 last year I knew I couldn't sustain
that that was like my emaciated [ __ ]
you know underwear model weight but I
still you know know there's never been a
redheaded underwear model a male one I
don't think you know but there's always
a first so I really want to be like 172
so I just said you know I started
yesterday I got my birthday coming up on
June 10th and there cannot be an 8
anywhere in my body weight on my
birthday for life I've just decided that
that's it it's not [ __ ] happening so
this morning I was one 81.6
you know I got my gym right outside my
back's feeling good I'm actually doing
[ __ ] legs and eggs today right legs
and eggs the fog late hey guys come on
down four legs and eggs right I'm
[ __ ] doing some squats and I'll do
the gym is the [ __ ] the [ __ ] speed
bag the atomic holes the pegboard I just
walk right up I want to [ __ ] bench I
don't have to worry about anything you
know I got a wireless [ __ ] right I
actually don't I have this some I got
this other thing looks like a Marshall
amp looks like the head of a Marshall
amp and you just plug your phone in
there and and I just crank like [ __ ]
AC
DC and [ __ ] all the [ __ ] that I love
guns and roses and all that like back in
the day and my goal is one time in my
life did I ever put up to 25 and sleep
until you meet heads left over from the
[ __ ] 80s 225 was the [ __ ] because
that was 2 45 pound plates on both sides
right and you just brought it down and
right back up again and I did that back
when I weighed about a buck 65 so I am
an old man now so right now you know I
just got the 45s on either side you know
I'm working my way back and I also know
how to build myself up without hurting
myself I always make sure if I'm going
to go 20 pounds up that I can do 20
pounds less at least six times and then
I just go up and see you know if I can
do 20 pounds up like two times maybe
three and I just work my way up so I
literally started out with just 25 on
either side you know did that 10 times
and I threw the 35 10 times and I'd put
the 45s on I could only do it like six
[ __ ] times pathetic but now back up
to ten reps on all of those and I just
moved up to a buck 55 which I put up
like four times so I should have my 80s
body back soon you know we just totally
over developed up top and then I have my
chicken legs now it's not happening this
time this time I'm actually going to do
the [ __ ] school the squats so anyways
if anybody else has those atomic holds
like what are you because they give you
those those little those plastic bands
that you then put like the C clamp on
and then you can swing from those things
like what do you hook the plastic thing
from I got them on my chin up bar but
but the [ __ ] in the ceiling is like a
fish hook but it's totally closed so I
can't put the plastic thing in there I
guess I could just [ __ ] email the the
company and I could figure out how to do
it anyway so let's let's uh literally
babbling here oh who do you guys like in
a Stanley Cup Playoffs huh and the
Stanley Cup final I got to tell you
after watching the Sharks beat my blues
I have
nothing but respect for those guys now
and I actually really liked that team
but then I got a ton of friends in
Pittsburgh I don't know I don't know I
don't know what to do why is Sidney
Crosby so hateable is that the pouty
lips
was it the crying after every [ __ ]
call for so many [ __ ] is the guy's
unbelievable he's unbelievable I don't
know I have no idea who's going to win
that one but I'm gonna watch bartnik
actually invited me over I got to get
back to him maybe I'll be able to run
over there and watch this then if I go
over there I'm not one of those douches
that even if I wanted San Jose to win I
would go over then I definitely roof for
the pent you can't when you see how
happy Joe Barton is any time the
Penguins score a [ __ ] goal there's no
way to not root for the Penguins and I
might root for the Penguins I'm just
rooting to see Joe bartnik happy all
right here we go the questions for the
weak weak weak weak weak online-dating
from a lady hi bumbling Billy butter
balls hey I like that one fumbling
rumblin bumbling stumbling um I actually
tweeted about you see that four-year-old
kid fell into the gorilla enclosure and
then they killed the gorillas I said I
tweeted about that I was saying how
before year old does not fall
accidentally fall into a gorilla
enclosure I wrote that was a fun hashtag
Chris Berman is a fumble that gorillas
got it all right I am a 26 year old lady
and I met this guy I am really into on
an online dating app I am NOT on the app
for hookups and don't think he is either
we have met we have met up in public
places three times in the past week and
I can really see potential with them
that's so I'm so [ __ ] jealous that
you guys have that app where it's like
I'm not on that just to hook up with
people like you literally can turn
yourself into like a gigolo or a call
girl with regular [ __ ] people it's
unbelievable he said we have met up in
public places three times in the past
week
and I can really see potential with him
I haven't been to his actual apartment
yet but met him once in the parking
garage of his complex that sounds like a
[ __ ] sorry I should mess up that out
he wants to hang out and watch a movie
at his place I'm not approved naive or
getting any weird vibes or red flags on
him I just don't want to put myself in
any potentially dangerous situations or
give him any false signs how soon is too
soon after meeting someone online to
hang out at their apartment dude what
the [ __ ] I don't know I have no idea you
don't sound comfortable so I wouldn't do
it
I wouldn't do it I would I think if
you're going to spend time alone with
him for the first time I would do it at
your place and have 9:1 dialed in the
phone in your hand I mean I don't know
if you're getting this kind of a creepy
vibe are you going to creepy vibe
because you met him online I have my
advices I would not go over there
anytime soon until that whole [ __ ]
vibe goes away and whether you're a
prude or not has nothing to do with
anything that just has to do with being
smart Jesus Christ now you got me
thinking there's something wrong with
them you know what stay away from that
guy all right boyfriend doesn't want a
dog I don't know how to say this hey
Billy is that a French word be été with
the little hat on the first day now I
got to look it up you know what happens
when I do this [ __ ] all right
oh you don't actually was looking up the
other day because I'm a big fan of the
83 Philadelphia 76ers I was looking up
the st. Louis spirit which was a an ABA
team French to English translation there
we go it's an ABA team I mean stupid
ha ha you [ __ ] [ __ ]
a billy stupid was I going to say I
actually looked it up the other
saint-louis spirits and did some of the
cool nicknames coolest nicknames ever
they had a guy bad news Barnes fly
Williams and then Moses mullah Moses
didn't even need a [ __ ] nickname with
it with the with this said it being his
real name Moses Moses Malone bad news
Barnes fly Williams and I watched I
don't want this I mean there's a 34:30
on it it seemed like I saw a trailer for
it Bob Costas was going like you need to
know anything about the ABA that team
was the [ __ ] ABA everything that was
great about it and I believe Bob Costas
is a Missouri guy and so I think that he
was doing all those games if I ever meet
Bob Costas that's the [ __ ] I'm going to
ask him about out of [ __ ] everything
that's what I would want to talk to him
about is about the ABA where he got his
start and all I just can't [ __ ]
believe that you know he got to see all
that stuff so anyways here we go Billy
Billy bet Billy stupid alright yeah I'm
a long time lady listener I love you
stand-up specials and f is for family is
amazing thank you
nice work thank you thanks again I'm 29
and I just moved away from Seattle to
San Antonio with my Air Force pilot
boyfriend all right well how does some
of that one go off we go into the wild
blue yonder this is my first time living
away from home and he's gone a lot for
work I thought it would be a good idea
for us to get a dog to keep me sane I
love animals and was a part-time dog
walker in Seattle
my boyfriend however has never owned a
pet in his life and isn't hot on the
idea of having a dog he's from Iowa and
he believes livestock should live
shouldn't live indoors oh Jesus I've
owned cats and dogs my entire life in
fact I had to leave my 17 year old cat
behind in Seattle and it broke my heart
can you offer any persuasive words to
help bring him around or should I just
drop it thanks to the laughs and go
[ __ ] yourself how do you bring them
around well you can do what my wife did
and you foster air-quote a rescue dog
that's what happens you foster a rescue
dog which means ya just have it for the
weekend and as the bit when in my act
I went from there's no [ __ ] way I'm
keeping this dog and in a 48-hour period
went all the way to oh my god this
thing's going to die someday how am i
emotionally going to be able to handle
this
you could do that I don't know this is
what I would do either way no matter how
this works out I would get a small dog
okay small dogs small problems okay
small expenses small shits to pick up as
your house breaking the [ __ ] thing I
was training whatever the [ __ ] is not
a horse bill you don't ride the thing
how would you do this well it sounds
like he doesn't want to do it why would
he call it live so it's not livestock
it's a [ __ ] pet I don't know you know
what it is this is the thing if you
foster a dog this is what's going to
happen so this guy grew up on a farm or
grew up in Iowa this is the thing when
you [ __ ] come home on a farm a cows
not flipping out and excited to see
neither is a horse they can do little
things but nobody gets excited like a
[ __ ] dog you know what I mean
it's like Dick Vitale right every time
you come home your dog flips out like
you just dumped the ball on a fast break
and the other team called timeout that's
the way your dog [ __ ] reacts now I
know from experiences when I was just a
boy and I would walk to school and I
used to feed this horse every day on the
way bill is just a Tom Sawyer movie no
it isn't this was my childhood and I
remember one time it wouldn't come over
so I walked away and I [ __ ] when I look
back it was doing that Walker was
nodding its head and flipping out for
whatever [ __ ] reason it was like
playing hard-to-get so I know that they
can I guess on some level show a certain
level of emotion but like I think maybe
I don't know what kind of dog you get a
little dog that has a nice mushed up
face you know maybe like one of those
French bulldogs something that snores
and farts see if your boyfriend can find
it funny I have no idea maybe a dog like
that but uh I find it hard to [ __ ]
believe unless he grew up on a farm and
anybody grew up on a [ __ ] farm on a
certain level like they got this
cold-bloodedness to them you know what I
mean they just seem too much they've
seen [ __ ] animals slaughtered you know
you know like when they're a kid like
their dad goes you want chicken for
dinner is that what you want
quit your crying you want chicken for
dinner all right he come out here you
come out here right come on out which
ones is going to be dad I don't want you
anymore no you said you want a chicken
now pick one out boy if you don't
[ __ ] I'm going to [ __ ] have you
for dinner period all eyes not one then
he [ __ ] just grabs it puts it on the
chopping block and then hands that kid
the [ __ ] Claver well I'll do it how's
that doing all right they lived through
that it like the age of six so they
don't look at animals the way we do and
I got to be honest with you I'm at one
time I saw this guy shoot a [ __ ] cow
because it was bullying the other [ __ ]
it was a shot a steer because it was
bullying the other steer they couldn't
figure out why the you know you know
they did come back you know the next
morning and like two or three cows look
like they [ __ ] somebody try to do a
scratch to extrapolate some [ __ ]
information problem right that's right
we're done er but they got slapped
around you know like they walked into a
door and they couldn't figure what the
[ __ ] slapping the [ __ ] out of these
stare and it turned they figured out
which one it was so they were like I we
got to kill this [ __ ] thing but
here's the deal we don't want the thing
to be stressed before it's killed
because that will affect the taste of
the meat so what they do is they just
sort of but do boo boo do they just sort
of pen it in
you know are you doing
dupa dupa do and then they just [ __ ]
take out a gun plan they [ __ ] kill it
right and I was like oh my god so then
they the guy had like this [ __ ] this
tractor and they tied up the back things
the back of its legs they tied up its
back legs and then they just lifted it
up off the ground then they gutted the
[ __ ] thing all the Bloods pouring out
all the [ __ ] entrails and I'm just
sitting there going on I'm never eating
meat again
this is [ __ ] horrific right and then
they once they [ __ ] chop the head and
the legs off and they get they get the
fur to hide off and they started
chopping it up ah I went from like oh my
god I'm never eating meat again - my
mouth watering going holy [ __ ] look at
all those steaks and this guy was
cutting them in like four inch [ __ ]
slabs like Fred Flintstone [ __ ]
steaks and it's just like dude you could
literally eat yourself to death and not
get a third of the way through that
[ __ ] cow cattle on what a steer
whatever the [ __ ] it is so I think the
thing about it is is if you grew up in
Iowa anywhere near a farm that's how
they look and animals they look at it
like you know this is a food source and
don't get too emotionally attached to it
keep it outside do not give it a [ __ ]
name and when it can't make you any more
money you give it the old [ __ ] right
there Fred so he might be a lost cause
you know what I mean and as bad as that
might be for you I got to tell you like
the fact that he can wall off those
feelings like that is great if you ever
have an intruder because God help them
when that guy when the intruder gets
those farm hands around him [ __ ]
throwing bales of hay since he was four
years with the farm boy strength Jesus
Christ that's [ __ ] all those [ __ ]
every offensive lineman for Nebraska
just grew up [ __ ] punching steer in
the goddamn head the [ __ ] maniacs so
the fact that he grew up and I
might be a lost cause so I would just
say try fostering a dog and try to just
get get one that is cool and chill but
if you if your boyfriend's active maybe
you want something that's a little more
athletic but like you know you can have
a dog that just wants to chill while you
watch the [ __ ] game I mean that's the
best that's why I love my dog my dog is
[ __ ] shredded it makes me want to
workout but then also you know it is
down to take a nap any [ __ ] time you
want it's not like those sheep herd and
[ __ ] lunatic dogs that have like a
Dede and if you don't give it a project
it starts [ __ ] eating the door you
know but anyways good luck with that
[ __ ] all right
Beyonce's album dear Billy Def Jam my
girlfriend was listening to the new
Beyonce album for a couple days straight
I let her listen because we usually
listen to my music which is music she
loves anyways I didn't say it's funny I
let her listen if you know it's okay you
can listen to that I didn't say anything
for the first few days but then I just
started getting sick of hearing the same
songs she understood this and did not
take offense because she's a great girl
and I don't waste my time with shitty
girlfriends who can't communicate dude I
got to admit right now at this point you
sound like you know a girl's a great
girl as long as she wants to do
everything you wanted to do she's a
great girl I'd say I'm sick of the two
days I'm sick of your music and she's
been listening to your music for [ __ ]
ever maybe I'm reading into this anyways
later that night were at a bar with her
friends or with her friend who is really
who has a really annoying name that
rhymes with small lean she brings up the
album the Beyonce album and how great it
is and my girl laughs and says yeah I
burnt this guy out with it pointing to
me her friends saw this is an opening to
regurgitate every stupid soundbite she's
read on a blog apparently I'm not
comfortable with women being in a
dominant position or if a guy did what
she did I wouldn't care yeah I know this
happened when that Alanis Morissette
album came out and I remember enjoying
some of the music and some woman in a
bar was going like do you even know what
this song is
have like like I should like like like I
had some relationship with the Lantis
and she was yelling at me like I don't
understand it you know I mean the song
see the [ __ ] you know you either like
the music or you don't I don't give a
[ __ ] what she's singing about right at
the end of the day yes he could [ __ ] we
[ __ ] be singing row row row your boat
if it sounds good I'm going to listen to
it like I'm not necessarily a fan of her
[ __ ] but that one that she did with Jack
White I like that song because because
the song sounds good and I've heard it
like 10 times because Mia's been playing
it and I cannot tell you one [ __ ]
lyric in it I don't know I don't even
know what it's about but anyways I
finally had to interrupt her and explain
that while I think she's what she's
singing about is annoying you said it
annoying is annoying my only complaint
was that I was tired of hearing the same
song songs for three days straight she
wouldn't even listen ignoring me and the
words coming out of my calm mouth
dismissing logic I turned to my
girlfriend and said how can a girl as
smart as you have such such one dismiss
such a one-dimensional friend yep she
tossed what was left of her drink on me
wow this chick is way out of line it was
a beer bottle that was almost empty I
barely got any drops on me she got mad
when I laughed and turned and stomped
off did I say too much did I say too
little listen I'm not saying you're not
a dick I think I think you said I think
what you said was perfect you know what
I mean like to be honest with you at
some point your girlfriend should have
stepped in and eland penlight guys got
maybe she was guys guys settle down
settle down settle down but whenever an
album like this comes up I mean she she
realizes that that album is just like a
big [ __ ] it's not like you know just
like a
[ __ ] what do they call it trolling
isn't she just acting like that happen I
mean I don't think she let calluses grow
on her feet and do all that [ __ ] that
she said she always looks like she just
came from the spa and I don't give a
[ __ ] what that guy did I don't think
she's interrupting that maybe she made
the help go down and go through that pet
biblical [ __ ] that she was talking about
but uh but whatever you know they got to
have that [ __ ] you know not
everything's for you but I understand if
someone's like playing in Alvin three
days straight
you'd go [ __ ] nuts but I think yeah I
think you went too far because you
insulted your girlfriend's girlfriend by
in a roundabout way insulting your own
girlfriend you know but that you have to
understand like women like that like in
this day and age like this is like this
so into that [ __ ] that you're not going
to convince them one way or the other
and that's like the type of person that
acts like an [ __ ] and just goes you
know guys are intimidated by me and no
point of ever examining examining like
their own behavior it's like I did I
tell you what guys when I was in Seattle
and that woman came up and [ __ ]
slammed her hands on the stage because
like the stage was up to her chin and
I'd scared the [ __ ] out of me because I
couldn't see anything because the lights
on I thought someone had jumped on stage
and I felt like that jolt like right
before you going to get into a fight and
I looked down and there was this woman
you know screaming at me or whatever and
I just said first of all she was
standing there forever and no security
did anything and I joked I said to the
guys in the crowd be like dude how many
times would we have been choked out at
this point and dragged out of here and
thrown into the throne into [ __ ]
traffic this is one of these women
privileged moments where you can just
disrupt the [ __ ] show and she's been
standing there yelling at me for like 30
seconds and nobody moved to do anything
and then finally I just said ma'am can
you can you please take your seat and
she goes oh I'll take my seat but I
don't need your permission
it's what she said and it was just like
it's like I get it you're a feminist but
like you know you're applying it like in
this instance I'm not the bad guy you're
you're the [ __ ] I know you have a
vagina so that makes you this terminal
victim in your [ __ ] world and that
you can never be in the run but believe
it or not at some point you can be the
[ __ ] [ __ ] and what you did was you
you remain calm which is the way to beat
anybody in a [ __ ] argument is as they
get heated you just stay calm and when
she had nothing else she threw your
drink at you and then [ __ ] stormed
off so it was weird you won that
argument but you or your girlfriend an
apology because you made [ __ ] weird
between her and her girlfriend and and
he kind of insulted your own girlfriend
in a way having said that I applaud you
for saying that because that's [ __ ]
hilarious
and I actually wish I could have seen
that because any times those types of
songs come out there's always that type
of [ __ ] of like you know are you just
saying that because this you're just
saying that because that and you know I
don't know it because you know what I
don't like about that [ __ ] is then you
just you just have this built-in [ __ ]
excuse so it's like oh so you're never
in the wrong if I call you out and say
you know XY and Z it's because of my own
issues it's never you Jesus Christ that
takes me back to Daisy Buchanan's in
like 1990 whatever when that Alanis
Morisette [ __ ] album came out all
right here we go um boxing or porn Jesus
Christ is a look at wide variety on this
one out dear bill I'm facing a dilemma
in my life and I was hoping to gain an
outside opinion I'm a 20 year old male
and I've always had aspirations of
becoming a professor
a boxer however I have a problem I fear
that I'm addicted to sex what I already
don't believe this this is such a
[ __ ] left turn I don't lose this is
causing problems in my relationship with
my fiance I absolutely I'm absolutely in
love with this woman
she goes out of her way to make me happy
sacrifice I got the hiccups I wolf down
my breakfast before this rum she goes
out of her way to make me happy
sacrifice so much just to be with me and
also pleasures me often Wow
what can you just say you have a nice
you have a wonderful sex life pleasures
me often I can picture you with your
head thrown back oh wow why would you do
that to me yet [ __ ]
alright the only problem is my sexual
frustration with her we have passionate
sex many times during the week but I
still want it even more eventually
ending up growing angry and resentful
towards her when she doesn't want to
Jesus don't go rub one out
and later feeling like an [ __ ] this
brings me to ask myself should I just
[ __ ] for a living my fiance and past
partners have always complimented me on
my performance in bed and my stamina
Jesus Christ this guy's going hard on
Memorial Day should we have a parade for
you going up to three hours on occasions
I love the sport of boxing and I've
always worked toward that but this
problem I have sometimes just makes me
want to drop everything and go [ __ ] the
world any any advice this is real or
fake this is great any advice you have
regarding this problem my relationship
or career path will be greatly
appreciated thanks and go [ __ ] yourself
well look if you're boxing you're in
great shape you know I don't know if you
got the porno dick or not but you
definitely got the stamina but you don't
want to go into that world if you have
other [ __ ] options you don't want to
go into that world and you know that I
really very few like the people who seem
to make them the zillions of dollars
which is still really hard to do at this
point because porno has become free
seems to be the women they seem to be
the ones that can become be a star just
because guys watch I guess way more of
it so I would say Jesus Christ am I
going to tell you to go get your head
kicked in or [ __ ] go join the dark
world of porn I would say boxing I would
swear I would do if I was you you know
you usually say if you have something
with your [ __ ] sex drive they always
say you know boxes right before a big
fight they abstain from sex for ten days
do you know your only problems you can
be coming in then your balls are going
to be feel like they're [ __ ] through
that the tarmac what avail you call it
the squared circle yeah I say you keep
[ __ ] boxing you abstain from sex and
hopefully you're good at you're good at
boxing you know that is not it that's
not a [ __ ] good profession to just be
okay at because you're going to be
[ __ ] you know your brain is going to
be mush why don't you - why don't you
try the UFC at least you got a chance
that you can tap out you can just get
[ __ ] get nothing you don't get
knocked out you don't take a bunch of
head shots in the UFC but I mean you can
get you know an armbar I'd rather have
an armbar than be knocked out because
you can tap out before they pop out you
[ __ ] dislocate your elbow you get choked
out which sounds horrific to me but
every professional fighter I've ever
seen like do it I'd much rather get
choked out than knocked up you just go
to sleep and then the ref stops it is
fine right I got to tell you that's one
of the oddest questions I've ever had I
don't know dude but God help you see if
you become successful as a boxer you're
going to become famous and god help your
relationship then
[Music]
there's no way to jerk it out of
yourself go out and lay on the front
lawn like one of those sprinklers just
[ __ ] you know shoot all your jizz out
and get on with you [ __ ] day to go do
your roadwork running with you hoodie
and your timberlands on I don't know
what to tell you dude that's that's way
beyond me you sound like you need a you
need a therapist Jesus Christ I want to
believe that that one was true I don't
know about that one but anyways that is
the podcast for this week happy Memorial
Day everybody enjoy your day off and
I'll check ya on on Thursday yeah that's
right
alright go [ __ ] yourself